i saw you and webby
were back together recently yeah uh
which uh obviously all your day one fans
have been waiting for that moment um
you know he's he's an interesting guy
you're an interesting guy
you guys uh is there gonna be any any
any more music being made between y'all
or something or is it just a moment i
think so the moment too sweet
and the bags would be too big if y'all
do that tour yeah man
you guys haven't gotten 750 000 right
now
you know that's crazy you're
just you right yeah no man we i got we
got we got an 85
licked the other day so so you guys are
60 by myself but you guys are actively
doing
stuff together right now as far as like
bookings right right we didn't did we
did three shows together but we gotta we
gotta get in the studio and come up with
a project and that'll
solidify the tour